I gotta pull up this story uh somebody
in the chat mentioned it and um I I is
Ironman either right now I saw this
beyond meat c-o-o arrested for biting
man's nose near Razorback Stadium he
just wanted to meet him he was hungry
you go that long without it yeah you're
just so desperate for it you'll take
whatever you can get I know I also like
the idea we could do a movie where it's
like after not after eating nothing but
beyond meat you become a zombie you just
your brain is like I need meat and then
you need to start eating people you do
you kind of do and you look at a lot of
the people who don't eat meat you know
the brain is largely fat for a reason
there there is you could tell you could
usually tell someone when when they're
on all vegan diet and there is a big
correlation with unhealthiness let's
just be real with each other let's be
let's be honest with each other we can
talk about pigs all we want but I think
the biggest attack Target always has
been cows cows are one of the most
nutritious one of the most amazing
animals on the face of the Earth Ian
loves them uh because of many different
reasons that I won't
but cows also are linked to the
progression of humanity because of the
amino acids the macronutrients and and
just the amount of nutrition that they
provide human beings is essential few
decades ago the majority of people had
cows we no longer have cows every family
had a cow yeah every family had a cow
majority majority of them yeah had a cow
because they needed there was a period
where like I was reading about it in the
city like or in the quote unquote
because they were smaller every family
had a cow yeah and whether it's raw milk
or beef liver you can't underestimate
the amount of nutrition that they
provide to the human beings that beyond
meat does not doesn't even compare and
we're also finding out that a lot of the
studies uh with beyond meat being
comparable in nutritional value have
been doctored have been altered and have
been faked you can't you can't pay
scientists off to come up I want to read
this this is really fascinating about
what happened it says just after 10 pm
an officer saw the man shuffling and
groaning down the sidewalk with his leg
Twisted in the wrong direction he raised
his hands hands vertically and started
saying brain
it says the owner of the Subaru got out
and stated that Ramsay pulled him in
close and started punching his body
Ramsay also bit the owner's nose ripping
the flesh off the tip of his nose oh man
he really just wanted meat and he
couldn't take it anymore they like
locked I mean imagine what happens to
your psyche when you he's like no one
was forcing him per se to eat nothing
but beyond meat but as the CEO he had to
keep up appearances yeah so he like
shows up to a Burger King and he's like
I just want a burger and then someone
goes hey you're the guy from Beyond me
and he's like that's right I'll have the
Beyond Burger
he walks in a restaurant and then he's
like I'm just gonna get the filet mignon
and the guy goes hey I know you you're
from Beyond me we got your burger ready
to go just like you like as you said I
use your salad when I was vegan for a
few years three or four years ago Luke
kind of what you were saying I I got my
skin started deteriorating I wasn't
getting enough B vitamins and I got
really angry I get really angry at
people eating animals I would be like
these blood suckers these mosquitoes
these vampires eating flesh sucking
blood I would get like how gross they
are like they need to Feast off of the
lit the animal living like it was so
weird it's just biology I I've made this
point before but I just gotta say it in
in lieu of you know what what Ian was
saying vegans are the real bad guys no
no no hold on I don't mind if you're
vegan I don't mind if you're carnitarian
I don't care if you're um omnitarian or
whatever you'd call it a pescatarian
pescetarian well you know you eat fish
and chicken but you don't eat steak and
mammal my point is
this whole argument that people are bad
for eating mammals because they feel
pain I look at it this way
if you've got two guys one guy is
growing his own food and eating it and
one guy is ransacking and killing other
farmers and eating their crops which one
is the bad guy it's obvious the dude
who's going around and ransacking is the
bad guy we don't like him right we want
him to stop now think about animals and
plant life plants minding their own
business absorbing free and abundant
sunlight taking in rain water and only
what they get to grow and live their
beautiful lives and then Along Comes Is
boar that just destroys the plant just
annihilates it and the plant was minding
its own business and I'm like yo that
boar just killed that innocent thing and
did nothing wrong and those boars they
attack people too so you know what I'm
saying you should be killing and eating
these wild animals the plants are the
ones who deserve to live now you want to
eat fruit an animal okay we just gotta
make sure you plant the seeds afterwards
because that's the point of the fruit
but to destroy the plant that did no
harm and in no way negatively impacts
you you see deer deer are real villains
going around just eating all the green
like those trees didn't do anything to
anybody but those deer you gotta watch
out for them part of what you're saying
about replanting the seeds of what you
eat is concerning about the fish
population because I heard you guys
talking about that before I wasn't in
the room but that were maybe they
believe that we're running out of fish
that we're overpopulated there's not
enough fish to feed the population but
there's this technology called iron
fertilization where they take iron dust
and they put it in the ocean and then it
creates Plankton the plankton eat the
iron it oxidizes and they eat it and
then all this Plankton Bloom appears and
that's food for fish and then all these
fish appear and you get these massive
Blooms of salmon off the northwest coast
of the U.S they did it a few years ago
people are like oh we gotta we gotta
hold back on this technology because it
might damage the environment dude iron
fertilization is the key and you can see
the river of blood in Antarctica is the
earth naturally fertilizing the ocean
with it's a river of iron it's this Red
Blood Red River just flowing in I
remember looking into this you're right
yeah you're absolutely right you can see
a glacier it'll break and then red water
because iron is preparing for the flood
because we're about to exit the Ice Age
and so he just gave me a really good
idea imagine this there's there's
there's this big cylindrical tube you
know a big tube and then it goes up to a
gigantic
what do you call it um what is it called
when you make those little terrariums
that are self-sustaining
um
yeah biospheres but you can you can make
your own where you get like a little jar
and then you put certain things in it
and close it and then the life will keep
because the humidity will come out and
then terrarium yeah a terrarium imagine
you made a self-sustaining fish tube
that had everything in it so the fish
could grow and then it absorbed enough
to where you could actually like a
vending machine go up and put in five
bucks and then it spits a fish out for
you and that fish is gross and it's
totally automatic taking care of itself
and then you have fresh fish nobody
needs to go fishing they're gonna run
out of fish yeah yeah no jellyfish to
worry about
hold the bag up and then it sprays the
fish and then you bring it home and then
you you cut it and you eat it boom
so cool we could streamline this whole
farming project right you could try as
long as they're not eating their own
feces
well it's got it gets recycled the
plants will do it and then you know oh
one thing I was thinking I was out of
the room but like at gas stations I
mentioned that if the power goes out you
can't pump gas do they have them set up
so that they use their own gasoline to
power generators so that you can
continue to Pump It Up Every gas station
I've never seen a gas station not when
the power is out they they all have
fossil fuel redundancies because that's
the most essential thing that you need
when the power is out you need you need
to look you need gas you need to run
your diesel generator you need whatever
I've never seen a gas station like have
no power it could have happened but I
think the one of the main reasons
nuclear is illegal is not because of the
danger because batteries are dangerous
the Lithium-ion batteries that you
remember the note was exploding or
whatever like those are dangerous too if
you puncture lithium ion battery it's
extremely dangerous can we see it in
water oh yeah yeah yeah and and the
crazy thing is this is really crazy is
you can buy lithium batteries in
airports and they they oxidize when you
expose like they have an air it starts
getting hot you put water on it it
bursts into flames exactly it bursts and
Flames put it on a plane and and but
that's why they give you warnings when
you're going on planes you can't bring
lithium batteries in so I don't think I
I think the issue is you got people like
Bill Gates you know Bill Gates is a
a Luke how would you describe the the
moral uh a very Blossom big man I was
gonna say how would you judge him
morally what how do you describe him
morally
um Mordor Mordor no you've got people
like him here's the problem we've got
Fusion breakthroughs ignition right an
ignition was reached yeah basically this
means we're gonna have extremely cheap
and abundant energy if we get this
process streamlined because you know
petroleum is extremely energy dense
nuclear is extremely energy dense and
fusion is even better but that's bad
news you know why for Bill Gates because
cheap free energy means cheap free food
it means humans are going to be able to
populate expand and expand dramatically
because energy is being being provided
extremely cheaply here's how it started
back in the early days of humanity
energy was human energy you would eat
stuff and then you would do stuff and it
was extremely difficult then one day
some dude was like I don't want to carry
these these logs yo that big Critter
right there I'm gonna tie them up and
make him do it they just eat grass all
day so then we started we used animals
and converted and you know we use
animals convert food into you know to
move things convert our energy then we
discover we could burn stuff wood we
would use wood for fuel then coal burned
better than petroleum now we got nuclear
now we got Fusion all of these are
dramatic escalations and our energy
output minus energy cost so it's way
more difficult to cut a tree down and
then use the tree for fuel once you get
Fusion going you got crazy clean energy
for a long time yeah the people are
going to use the power machines they're
going to use it to make food they're
going to have tons and tons of babies
and then we're going to have too many
people for Bill Gates
well they're all big population control
control freaks that's a huge part of of
the agenda no doubt but there was a on
Twitter earlier today I would love to
show you and pull up the chart but it
was the world population
population of the world from basically
as early as records go and you see the
spike at around 1880 and we started
drilling our first wells in 1880 and you
see the population and it's it's not a
it's not a curve it is just an absolute
it's flat and then it explodes and it
explodes because of fossil fuels and if
you are petrified of that and the people
who hate that the people who hate
population who want population control
they don't consider themselves to be the
peasants they consider themselves to be
the aristocracy and before then what was
there there were the super super rich
and everyone else served them and they
want to go back to that I honestly
believe that they don't want a middle
class that's that's arguing and and in
their way they want poor people who
serve and they want there it is there's
the chart thank you crazy look at the
population from literally the the first
commercial uh uh um oil well was was was
1888 I believe but just look how from
like 700 to 1800 the population barely
grows it's it's everyone who wants
reduced population considers themselves
the aristocracy just the way I always
say like when Bernie Sanders says he
wants to you know be a socialist it's
like well because you yourself you see
yourself as the party Elite you know you
don't see yourself as the peasant you
see yourself as the as the ruler also
the U.S barely grows what's causing this
dip now there's a dip this is the
projection uh Bill Gates oh okay you
think I'm kidding the dude gives TED
talks about how we need to have slow so
people need to understand Africa you
said Africa he said Africa needs to
control their population you say that uh
Bill Gates wants to reduce the
population they will tell you you're
conspiracy this and wrong what what Bill
Gates has that fact check is that we
want to slow population growth it's like
oh okay so what happens if you slow
population growth the older population
dies there's less younger people and you
see this chart the populations will
decrease because Generation X for
instance is larger than the millennial
generation well I think Millennials are
larger than the Gen X generation but
we're getting to the point now where the
generations are going to become even
then with slower population growth you
will come a point to where the older
generation dies in large numbers just
due to age yeah and then the next
generation is smaller and population
declines we'll see this in China after
the result of their two child one child
policy it's going to take a little while
still but eventually their numbers will
they're they're plateauing right now but
their numbers will start to dip
dramatically absolutely and if you look
at the projections worldwide population
is going to go down dramatically to the
point where we are going to be facing a
civilization crash that's going to be
very severe and something that we might
even see in our lifetime because the
numbers are clear as day the populations
are going down dramatically and we're
seeing that in Japan what's happening in
Japan is going to hit the rest of the
Western World in a very severe way
that's going to have some very negative
consequences are they just slowing their
growth or are they actually losing net
numbers losing absolutely losing they
sell more adult diapers now in Japan
than they do baby diapers so yeah you
could tell CB um that that 60 Minutes
thing was geared towards 75 year olds
there's like an old an old segment dude
when I looked at this this dip I thought
okay what would cause a dip like that
starvation and War but then I realized
no those are the people that are going
to Mars they're just doing Earth's
population no no no that's what that dip
is those are colonists that leave well
there's a national uh natural
progression that that many scientists
are saying this will just naturally
happen on its own the population will
Peak and then decline naturally but now
with so many external factors with so
many choices when it comes to what's
happening in our society and our culture
with our diet that number is going to be
even far worse off as of course there's
propaganda up on the corporate media
telling people don't have children it's
really bad for you it's bad for the
environment and people are listening to
that and deciding not to have children
which is one of the biggest best gifts
that you could have on the face of this
world so and again it's absolutely
mind-boggling to see this unfold right
in front of us and the population is
extremely declining and very dangerous
which is why the good people need to
have children good people need to have
children every time I say the lunatic
liberal couple who's like for the sake
of the climate we're not going to have
children I'm like good I don't want you
yahoos to reproduce anyway so I think
you're doing us all a service so but
those people who are good as one of them
is at the head of the table should have
as many kids as possible because the
good people should reproduce I saw you
tweeted out that you were like
I can't take this anymore that made me
so angry I wanted what was that tweet do
you remember yeah I was on an airplane
and this I hate to say anyone as as
trailer trash but trailer trash
mom um and you know I can't I ever I got
a lot of flack for people like you don't
know her backstory but like you can't
talk to a two-year-old like that this
was not like oh my God you're driving me
crazy this was and I can't say the words
because we're on YouTube but to like to
a two-year-old it was her own kids just
because she had another one in her arm
and she was saying how much she doesn't
like them and then when the kid was
finally crying she just laid into him
and I was like oh God and so we can't
have kids biologically that you know I
don't know or that is that confirmed but
you know that's a big point of view I'm
sorry we'll probably we're probably
trying to adopt and I keep putting out
feelers for like if you have a kid and
you know you're a pro-life mom if you're
a pro-life mom and you're like I don't
got pregnant but it's a mistake and I'm
in high school Daniel Turner PTF on
Twitter will pay for everything and
we'll get to keep the baby though so
I do like babies good people should have
babies even if they are of this you know
I I understand people's Hank but they
should have been and I hear you're going
to be feeding the baby fine steaks
and a lot of lamb we haven't talked
about the lamb how's the lamb we have so
many lamb and the population just grows
and grows and grows animals can we have
one I will bring you one wait can we
keep one to like own okay wait if you
give us two then like in a few years
we'll have a ton of land yes but you
just can't like have them I mean you
kind of you're gonna eat them but they
really shouldn't inbreed too much so I
can get we can ah we can we can sell you
a boy and a girl who are not related and
you can eat all of their kids but then
save the girls and then and then you
swap out the RAM for another one and
then get the daughters pregnant
you can do it one generation you're not
really supposed to just like you know
you always need new Bloodlines
um you know even with chickens to a
certain extent like not not the eggs is
fine but if you're actually growing your
chicken population you shouldn't have
like Brewster's mate with their own
that's not good for them one of uh one
of our chickens went Broody and it's
only like seven months it's not the best
so you're gonna stop it when they go
broody how how they they pancake it yeah
it's like how did you get so fat and
they just I love I love Omega what do
you do for the lamb um when you're ready
to eat them
um it depends upon weight how they're
have you know get them to the right
weight and then yeah we just it's kind
of sad because they know us so well and
they're so sweet and they are sheep
there's a reason why we call them sheep
and you just wave the little green
bucket and they get on the back of the
trailer and they eat and you just close
the door and say and then driving to the
slaughterhouse
no I don't I don't actually I bring them
to uh a place yeah a butcher abattoir I
think is the proper like fancy word but
it's but we use a very good Humane one
and you pay a little more for it and and
it's and it's fine do they March them
down and they put a bolt in their head I
don't know what they what they do is
they lock the sheep in a room and chain
their legs up and then psychologically
terrorize make them watch Clockwork
Orange
yeah the movie's brutal unnecessarily
cruel to the Sheep what what do they do
they do a bolt to the head right yeah
yeah yeah
um yeah and the good ones do it with
that you know that the other sheep
aren't there you know so like you don't
see your brother get you know but I
understand sometimes you have to we do
have to feed a big population you want
to do the most humane way I think we're
but we're best off trying to get as much
food as possible from ourselves
absolutely we do you know but geez
anyone that has a reaction to thinking
putting a bolt in the back of a sheep's
head is like dude do you eat meat well
then get over it yeah you should know
yep yeah yeah so we got to start cycling
the chickens at some point the rooster
has got to go but yeah we gotta eat the
roosters there's too many of them
Roberto is safe Roberto is uh he's a
good dude they're all his kids he has
too many so he's he's going to retire
into old age and live a good rooster
life he's actually really small you know
when when he was the only rooster
he was big to us and then once his kids
grew up we went whoa the dude must been
a run they thought it was a girl yeah
you know we got some Jersey Giants by
the way we got we bought four turns out
one of them I think is a boy well I just
think it's great that you went to the
Frederick County Fair and looked at the
chickens and didn't tell anyone that
your chickens have been on billboards in
Times Square
it's so cute they're putting their
little chickens in a cage so we can come
see them my chicken was seen by like 3.5
million people I think per week that's
right Roberto do you trade chickens with
other chicken Farmers I don't but you do
right yeah and you can usually and this
is where you know uh
um
social media groups can be really
helpful so farmers are the most
Cooperative people in the world they're
the original socialists but the good
socialists right they do Swap and change
and if I have a ram and you have a ram
we need to change the bloodline a lot of
times it's just you know if it's the
same can you do like blood work on them
make sure they don't have diseases and
stuff before they get traded around is
that normal sometimes people do a whole
bunch of testing like that yeah but I
mean I honestly I've gone to people's
Farms
um for sale that I can just tell in a
couple seconds and there are lots of
things you can look at you can look at
their eyes you can hear their breathing
you can see their weight but you can see
in a person's Farm within five seconds
if their Farm is good or not we have two
uh barred Plymouth Rock chickens Vanessa
and Dorothy Vanessa's got a furled brow
she always looks really angry Dorothy's
eyes are big and round and she always
looks kind of goofy and then we have a
bunch of these rooster boys that came
from these two hens and you can tell
which one was the Mom it's because they
have the same eyes it's like a bunch of
the boys are walking around with furled
brows all angry and they're like young
and they're really aggressive and then
the other ones are like really much
they're much more docile and their eyes
are big and round and they're like
walking around feel like I love how they
all have different personalities yeah
they are every chicken does have a
different person I want to eat them
they're pretty funny but my brother
doesn't want to eat them he wants naked
he wants he wants to let him fend for
themselves um do you have have you ever
processed like we can come do that with
you if you want it's it's a little gross
our our layers are so grossful and cut
their head off and then pull their
feathers out there's a big there's a big
cylinder that's the thing that that def
feathers them it spins them around oh I
we do it by hand oh by hand really yeah
there's a machine I saw it steam blasts
them and then spins them around it rips
all the feathers on then you just pick
it right out yeah but the the the
chickens the hens they're still laying
so no yeah hold on you gotta keep them
and then what by the time they stop they
stop laying though it's like not as good
right and eggs are the greatest things I
love eggs I could eat eggs all the time
little vinegar and a little cream salt
uh what else you put in there oregano
Yeah you mentioned raw milk earlier and
I was surprised that you did because
it's highly illegal right the the way
the government cracks down on raw milk
fascinates me
um but but it's absolutely nonsensitive
it's insane yep it's insane I'm sorry I
don't interrupt but like with collecting
your own rain water but continue is it
because they're afraid of disease I I
don't understand what the Crackdown on
raw milk is it it makes absolutely no
sense at all the rainwater thing is
typically in more denser areas they just
don't want it to Fester bacteria and
stagnant water they they don't want it
to I forgot what it was but um
I was talking to a guy in the suburbs of
Jersey and he mentioned that if
everybody was collecting it it would
like limit runoff or something like that
and then you know I can't remember what
he said but it's not necessarily about
stopping you from having your own water
to drink it's about pollution and stuff
maybe something like what you were
saying thanks for checking out this
segment from the timcast IRL podcast but
if you want to check out the full show
live tune in Monday through Friday at 8
pm and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
timcast IRL podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in Monday through
Friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there